LIKE JUST ABOUT EVERY THING ELSE
IN THE WORLD, SPORTS IS BEING
CONSUMED BY A WOKE IDEOLOGY.
ATHLETES PROTESTING THE ANTHEM,
ESPN PREACHING SOCIAL JUSTICE,
BIOLOGICAL MALES RYAN O'MALLEY
RECORDS IN    IN THE MAIL SPORTS
RECORDS IN    IN THE MAIL SPORT.
BARSTOOL SPORTS MEANWHILE IS IT
WITH A SENSE OF HUMOR.
THAT'S THE MOST OFFENSIVE PART
TO MANY.
THEY ARE FUNNY AND FOR THAT THEY
COME UNDER CONSTANT ATTACK.
MOST RECENTLY, NBC NEWS PIECE
FALL TO THE WEBSITE FOR BEING A
BASHING OF TRIBUTE TRADITIONAL
MASCULINITY.
DAVE PORTNOY FOUNDED BARSTOOL
SPORTS AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
NBC HAS GONE AFTER YOU FOR BEING
MASCULINE.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE?
>> NOT ONLY MASCULINE BUT THE
LIKE IN SPORTS.
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH SPORTS.
LITERALLY.
DIRECT QUOTE.
THERE ARE SOME HE HAD SCHEDULES
AND THIS ARTICLE I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHERE TO START BUT THAT'S
IT.
THEY SAY WE ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
CONSERVATIVE, NOT REALLY TRUE.
WE ARE APOLITICAL.
I'VE TOLD YOU THAT.
BUT IT LITERALLY SAYS THEY ARE
ARE -- DAYS OF CONSERVATIVE
IDEOLOGY BECAUSE THEY WATCH
SPORTS.
GUESS WHAT, WE LIKE SPORTS.
WOMEN LIKE SPORTS TOO.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE MAKING THE NFL
LEG WELL, THE NFL MUST BE
CONSIDERED GOOD BECAUSE GUYS
LIKE FOOTBALL.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
IT NONE.
ZERO.
>> Tucker: IT DOESN'T.
IT DOESN'T PAY BY THE WAY, I'VE
SAID THIS BEFORE, I WOULD BE
SHOCKED IF THERE ARE A LOT OF
WHITE WINNERS ON YOUR STAFF, YOU
ARE DOING WHAT YOU'VE ALWAYS
DONE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MOT
DONE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MOV
DONE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MOE
DONE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MOC
DONE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MOA
DONE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MOG
DONE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MOS
DONE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MO.
SO THE PIECE CONTAINS A QUOTE
FROM THE FOLLOWING.
LISA NAKAMURA WHO IS DESCRIBED
AS A PROFESSOR AT ANN ARBOR WHO
STUDIES THE INTERSECTION OF
DIGITAL MEDIA, RACE, GENDER, AND
SEXUALITY.
>> THAT HURTS.
I'M A MICHIGAN GUY.
THAT'S MY SCHOOL.
WE ARE GETTING EMBARRASSED BY
THIS LADY.
IT IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE MORE
SERIOUS THREATS.
THAT YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
ARTICLES, ALL THE PROFESSORS AND
ALL THESE SCHOOLS, IT'S LIKE
WHAT ARE YOU TEACHING THESE KIDS
AND BY THE WAY, TUCKER, WE REACH
OUT TO THESE PEOPLE, HEY, DO YOU
HAVE ANY INTEREST IN DEFENDING
ANYTHING YOU SAY?
NONE OF THEM GO.
THEY DON'T CALL US, THEY DON'T
TALK TO US, THEY JUST MAKE UP
STUFF.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE COWARDS.
THEY WON'T COME ON THE SHOW
EITHER.
SO HAVE YOU EVER HAD ANYBODY
RESPOND AND SAY YEAH, I WOULD
LIKE TO DEFEND THE PROPOSITION
THAT IT'S WRONG FOR A SPORTS
SITE TO COVER SPORTS OR DO THEY
JUST IGNORE YOU?
>> THEY SAY NO.
A LOT OF THIS ARTICLE SAYS WE
ARE GOING BACK IN TIME LIKE AS A
ME TOO MOVEMENT AND WOMEN ARE
GETTING MORE POWER IN DIFFERENT
PLACES WE ARE REJECTING THE
NOTION.
OUR CEO IS A FEMALE, BY THE WAY,
WHICH IN ITS OWN RIGHT IS
INSULTING TO HAVE TO BRING UP.
SHE'S A CEO BECAUSE SHE'S
BRILLIANT.
I DIDN'T HIRE HER BECAUSE SHE'S
FEMALE.
SHE IS AWESOME AND THE RESULTS
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES BUT WHAT
ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
IN OUR CMO'S, OUR CFO IS A
FEMALE, YOU LOOK AROUND LIKE WHA
FEMALE, YOU LOOK AROUND LIKE WHT
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
YOU'RE JUST MAKING STUFF UP.
THAT'S WHY THEY DON'T ANSWER.
NBC, HEY, I'VE OFFERED TO GO ON
THAT SHOW PRETTY KNOW WHAT THEY
DO?
THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THEY KNOW I
HAVE NO ANSWER.
THE ONLY GO ON FOX COMING ONLY
DO TUCKER.
TUCKER, YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE WHO
LETS US BE GREAT I'LL SPEAK TO
ANYBODY, ANYTIME, ANYPLACE, BUT
IF THEY ARE AFRAID TO HAVE THESE
QUESTIONS, WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO
DO?
YOU WON'T LET US GET OUR STORY
OUT STORY OUT.
>> Tucker: I WORKED THERE FOR
FOUR YEARS AT NBC SO I KNOW HOW
MANY PIGS WORK THERE FOR REAL.
BUT I WONDER, GIVEN THEIR DEEP
COMMITMENT TO FEMINISM, WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE PROFITS
FROM THE LIMBIC'S DO THINK THEY
ARE GIVING TO WOMEN'S
ORGANIZATIONS?
>> ALL I KNOW IS THEY KILLED THE
HARVEY WEINSTEIN STORY.
LOOK IN A MIRROR.
JUST LOOK IN THE MIRROR NBC IT.
I WILL GLADLY GO ON YOUR SHOW
EVEN THOUGH YOU DON'T HAVE --
WHEN I PRESENT YOU THE FACTS
YOU'RE GOING TO TURTLE.
YOU'RE GONNA ROLL OVER.
THEY JUST MAKE STUFF UP AND IF
YOU CAN'T DEBATE IF THEY WHAT
ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO DO?
BY THE WAY, THEY MAY HAVE
ACTUALLY --
IF THEY THINK IT'S A PROBLEM TO
WATCH SPORTS, GUESS WHAT,
CONSERVATIVES HAVE THE
PRESIDENCY FOR THE REST OF TIME
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE SPORTS.
>> Tucker: SO ANDY LACKING A
RED NBC KILLED THE HARVEY
WEINSTEIN STORY AND NOW ACCUSE
YOU OF SEXISM.
I WONDER, WHAT EITHER ONE OF
THOSE EVER DO AN INTERVIEW WITH
YOU?
>> YOU THINK?
DO YOU THINK ANY OF THEM ONE?
AGAIN, THE FACTS ARE SO HEAVILY
WEIGHTED ON OUR SIDE, YOU READ
THAT ARTICLE.
THERE WERE SENTENCES IN THAT
ARTICLE, I READ THEM A HUNDRED
TIMES.
I THINK ABOUT FAIRLY SMART
PERSON, I STILL DON'T KNOW IF
THEY WERE TRYING TO GET OUT.
THE DEAN OF COMMUNICATIONS AT AT
PENN STATE, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE SAID, I WOULD
NEVER LET MY KID IN HER CLASS
BUT WHAT WORLD IS SHE IN?
SAYING "SPORTSCENTER" IS GOING
BACK IN TIME?
I TUNES ENTITY.
I'M HAPPY TO DEBATE A BIT I GO
TO YOUR CLASS, MARIA HARDING, I
WILL LET YOU HAVE THE MODERATOR,
I WILL LET YOU PUT YOUR PEOPLE
IN, AND I WILL PUT YOU IN A
MENTAL PRESS WHOLE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE NO FACTS.
>> Tucker: NOTES ON YOUR KIDS